>> ALL RIGHT SEA GIVEAWAY IM
IAN MING IN FOR
LAURINGRAMPECIAL EDITION
OF "THE INAHAMNGLE" A LOT
GOING ON.
AS IT RELATES TO POTENTI
TAIWANRIP R NANCY PELOS.
AL POIS OF THEPEAK MAKING
THE VISIT IWOUL HAPPEN I
ST AF A FEWOURS ABOUT 12
HOUR BINDS ANDF ANHING
HAPPS WILL TELL YO RIGHT AWAY
SPENDSHE NIGHT IN TPEI ORS TOTAE
NOT.
THEY'VESSUE THREA FORHE
SPEAKECELEATIONS AYOU
PROBLY KNOW SAYG YESTERD
THATHE MILITY WL NOT SIT
BY WLE SHE VISITS REAY?
THEOINGVEN FURER PROMING
LITA INVOLVEMENT CATEVEN
SUGGTING THA TY MIGHTHOOT
HER ANE WN ALWAY ON THA
NI ANDHEHINE MITAR
PU THEIDICULOU PROGANDAVIDEO SOS
ODUCOF THEIR TROOP
UNCHING MISSIS AND TING
OFF AND FIGHT JET
IT'S NE B THEY HAVE A
LITARY A AAPE RECORDER.
THEY SEEHIS ISSUE THA THE
HE STAED WITH WHEOR ANOUR.
WHITE USE S SUPPOIVEF A
POTEIAL VISIFROMHE SRT.
>> W WASHE SPEAKER BEING
GED NOT  GO?
WHO URGEDER N TO GO
>> Ban: YES IT'S TR THAS
ACTLWHAT THERESINT SAID.
THENTI APPRANCE OKIRB
SA THA THE WHI HOUSE I
KIND OF SCAR.
THEY TK OTHE TON THEY COULD
DIFFERENAL TARDSHE D AND
GRELIN TOWARDSHE PRESIDE.
>> W HAVE REATEY SAID THAT
WEPPOS A CHANGES TO THSTUS Q FRD
WEAVE ID THAT WE DOOT
SUPPT TAIWAN INDEPENDENC AND
CROSS TRADE DIERENS TO BE
RESOED BY PEEFUL MEANS.
Brian: WHY IS TT
NECEARY?
NEVE MINTHE FACT THA HIS
BOSSHE CMANDER ICHIEJUST
TWO MONTHS AGO TT O COUEE
WOULD DEFEND TAIN INDENDEE
MEMB?
WOU FIGHT I TAIWAN WAS
VADE
THMESSING ONLY GOT WSEFR THE AFE
TH BEFING ROOM AND COM
KAEMOHN PRRE.
THR DAYSOW SINCE T
CHINE TEATENED TO MURR
NANCY LOSI
WHERE  T PSIDE COMING
OUT TO RESND ATEASTO SAY
DOTO THAT?
>> KBY W JUST HE TALNG
OUT,'VE NOT EN TSE
REPORTS.
>> THE OREGANOAY BE SHOOWN
HERLANE OR  WOULDE IN
THR RIGHTSO SOT DOWN THE
ANE.
NEED FOR THIS TE OF RATING.O
WAS SOMEOUNTRY THA WAND TO
SHOO DOWN T SPEAKER RIG OUT
OF T SKY ALL RIGHT MAY IT
WAS INA ANKS FORHOOTG ME
OULET'S GE THISTRAIT
WHITE USERESS SECRETARYAS
AWAROF THE CHINESEHREAT,
UNITED STATES?E SPEAKERF TH
TH'S NOT TOO REAUR